you are very entitled little spoil brat
is what you are you're
a come to India honey come to J por I'd
love to meet you come on baby I'll give
you my address what is she going to do
fight an elderly woman no shade Jenny oh
okay okay Jenny gets a little gangster
on Kimberly after she calls her the
seaword during part one of the 90-day
fiance the other way tell all if you
don't know what the CW word is look it
up it's looked at as one of the most
offensive words you can call someone
especially a woman Kimberly I think I
mean you're being disrespectful to them
I don't feel like I was being
disrespectful uh yeah you are horrible
let's get into
it hey 90day fans famam it's melissia I
hope you're doing well the other way
season 5 tell all is here it came pretty
fast and I am not complaining all right
before we get into into Jenny and
Kimberly let's get into one of my
favorite parts of the tell all when the
cast sees each other for the first time
in the green room before heading to the
stage I was excited to meet you guys so
we can all trauma Bond the first
standout moment was seeing Julio rocking
his burnt orange suit I forgot he was on
this season him and Kiren they broke up
and just disappeared off the show and
the wild part is that I didn't even
notice they were
missing damn it is hard to be in New
York alone I miss turkey and I miss
sarper so my heart is there in comes
shakina looking like a Barbie but during
this moment China's a little salty
because Danielle didn't say hi back to
her well I said hello to Danielle and
she didn't say hi back so she didn't no
she just kind of seems like she's
Superior to everyone like she's on
another level and like she's too good
I'm not going to lie that's something
that would have made me feel some type
of way too but then Shak kind goes on to
say she never really liked Danielle in
the first place I never really cared for
Danielle so it makes you wonder is that
true or does she not like Danielle now
because she ignored her which by the way
is not surprising I would not put that
past
Danielle hi
everyone look at Shina are you still in
the Dr I am oh wow Kenny oh wow that old
wow was loaded it said a lot without
saying much oh wow I never really cared
for Daniel I don't know something about
her rub me the wrong way I felt like she
had very specific reasons to choose
Johan as a partner I think she liked the
way he looked she liked the size of his
but I think she went into that
relationship looking to change him and I
felt like she kind of manhandled him she
kind of I want to back you up in this
moment girl because you are making some
some valid points but aren't you doing
the same thing with Ken from the Dark
Side over here you like the way he looks
sarper is a model and a personal trainer
he's just the most stunning man I've
ever seen you said you love the way he
puts it down in the bedroom our sex life
is just like out of this world it's
insane you're also trying to change him
from a man who has slept with 2500 women
to a one woman man
oh we've talked about him having female
clients and kissing women on the cheek
and we agreed that he's not going to do
that and he's doing both so basically
what's bothering her about Danielle is
what she needs to take a look at in her
own
life okay getting married to TJ has been
a definite adjustment Kimberly arrives
at the tell all and admits she hates
mared life nobody told me how much
marriage sucks
and it does did she think the marriage
papers were just going to magically
erase their problems also what happened
to her being psychic I am Clairvoyant I
am able to see energies figures I am
clar cognizant which is having this
overall knowing
feeling I am clear audience I can hear
messages from my Spirit guides from
other people's Spirit
guides and
M there's so many different
claes what happened to that part of her
storyline we haven't seen her tap into
any of her abilities or even talk about
them since the beginning of the season
the question that needs to be raised is
Kimberly what do you say to viewers who
are confused about why you were not able
to foresee an unhappy marriage with TJ
I'm genually curious welcome to 90-day
fiance the other way the couples tell
all fast forward to the actual tell all
where we see Brandon and Mary on video
chat from the Philippines and they
reveal the name of their daughter
midnight Midnight it's a unique
name Kenny and his subtle
reactions yeah the creativity is getting
real out here and I love unique names
too but I've never heard or thought of
midnight I would like to know why
midnight I believe names are powerful
you're speaking something over someone
constantly and midnight honestly in my
opinion seems like a heavy name to give
someone I hope Mary and Brandon share
their inspiration at some point but what
we do know is that midnight was born on
August 15th via C-section and Mary tells
ET when I heard our baby crying for the
first time I got teary eyed and was so
happy to realize I have a baby adding
I've never been this happy in my whole
life oh that statement just made my baby
fever worse all right moving along Johan
and Danielle are still separated yes
after we found out in the last episode
that he's allegedly been cheating on
Danielle throughout their entire
marriage and before they tied the not
the other day a woman wrote to me on
social media and told me that she has
been in a relationship with my husband
for 2 years since a month before we got
married yeah it's looking like that will
be discussed more next week in part two
of the tell all they all have some
connection to these couples please
welcome Tim Kanani Andre and in a
surprising twist some 90-day ogs join
the conversation to share their opinions
on the couple's relationships including
Jenny and Smit who joined in from India
of course their connection is with TJ
and Kimberly also an American woman and
Indian man living in India and yes
Kimberly is still living in India in the
apartment on top of TJ's family's home
she's just in the states for this hell
so I'd love to get your take on Kimberly
and TJ's relationship post Sean Robinson
ask Jenny and Smit what are some of the
things that stood out to them and Jenny
doesn't hold back Kimberly to me seemed
very unappreciative of everything what
she got was amazing to me and she didn't
she appreciated nothing yeah Jenny is a
prime example of when you start
complaining you might want to remember
that there is somebody who would love to
be in your position smit's parents did
not want anything to do with Jenny let
alone let her live in close quarters
with him and throw her an elaborate
wedding her saying I hate
India it it broke my heart like that
broke my heart I can't believe she you
said that your opinion doesn't matter to
me Jenny well your opinion doesn't
matter to me either first of all respect
India respect India or don't be here I
don't want to darling I don't want to
don't call me darling I am not your
darling okay keep your in
America Julio's facial expression is
mine right now why is Kimberly laughing
darling okay aside from it being a
little creepy does she really think this
is funny or is she doing that childish
thing where you laugh when someone's
upset to make them angrier keep your in
America okay wow you can laugh all you
want but you know what you are very
entitled little spoiled brat is what you
are you're
a
oh oh she called you she called you the
seaw girl come to India honey come to J
poror I'd love to meet you come on baby
I'll give you my address oh okay okay
Julio's reaction is mine once
again first of all it is always a shock
when that gangster side of Jenny comes
out come to India honey come to Jore I'd
love to meet you y'all remember when she
went off after Smit put their marriage
license on hold behind her
back are you embarrassing the yeah Jenny
can go there she basically told Kimberly
come outside and then you have Smit over
there rolling up his
sleeves but really what is Jenny gonna
do give Kimberly a spanking Kimberly is
30 and Jenny is 65 this little back and
forth just feels
inappropriate and unnecessary can't
really I think I mean you're being
disrespectful to them I don't feel like
I was being
disrespectful TJ what the hell
man oh she is uh she is quite enough to
respond everybody yeah as we've seen
this season when Kimberly feels like
there's a threat she tends to take
things to the extreme I think it's a
defense mechanism because that response
felt like not warranted by that's what
part of your problem is like with him is
cuz you elevate it like you don't try to
bring it down you keep bringing it up
yep look the moment you realize that you
don't have to be right or get the last
word in every argument
is such a freeing experience that's
actually where the real power lies it's
when you accept that you have nothing to
prove and not winning the argument
doesn't take away from your value rather
than winning peace and the solution
becomes more important I think it's a
defense mechanism and when it comes to
Kimberly's Behavior seemingly being a
defense mechanism it's one she should
consider letting go of it might have
served her at some point in her life but
now it's getting in the way of her truly
connecting with people yeah I know Jenny
kind of came at her first but to Kenny's
Point instead of escalating it and
making enemies with Jenny you're a
Kimberly could have calmly stood up for
herself and then used Jenny as a
resource as of now it appears that
Kimberly plans to stay married to TJ and
live in India and you have Jenny who's
been living in the country for years as
an American Kimberly should get advice
from her Kimberly do you feel that you
have been disrespectful to the Indian
culture no I do not yes yes Kimberly
stay out of India please don't come back
speaking of Kimberly escalating
arguments host Sean Robinson calls for
the producers to pull up a clip of one
of Kimberly and TJ's most recent fights
and just take a look at the cast
reactions as they watch what you else
ask expect from me maybe give me a hug
and say I'm sorry you're
depressed you have all right to separate
with me also I'm telling you separate
from you kirson looks so uncomfortable
because
I'm no I said I don't you said you said
s
times shut up yikes but you know what
I'm not even gonna leave Kimberly on an
island by herself and act like I've
never had a moment where I've lost it
due to frustration now granted it might
not have been that intense but I can
relate just a little bit the way that
she comes at him and the way she speaks
to him is with 100% disrespect and
screaming like that oh what why TJ have
H have you seen this side of Kimberly
before or just when she moved to India
good question I never saw that tension
that agression and that voice ever
before that it was also new for me TJ
and I we're still learning each other
with the communication gaps we have so I
don't think that we're going to learn
unless we have these bumps in the
road cly like everything was handed to
her on a silver platter me I had to
fight for all of it I was respectful to
his parents the whole way through I was
always respectful to India I never
complained but you are horrible
something else that's horrible Kimberly
revealing that when she and TJ would get
into an argument he would go downstairs
and not talk to her for days the longest
they've
gone 3 days and these are newly WS oo
waa look at how she acts I would go
downstairs for days
too she kind of she put herself in the
situation and then she's playing a
victim she have a frustration makes
sense but you can communicate with the
wrong
Woods she brought her American attitude
with her to India you can't do that so
right now if I could do it over again I
would do things differently there you go
but I like that I I was able to learn
from saying those things the way I said
them well let's hope that she actually
learned and hey her husband is still
with her so maybe they really are
figuring things out well jinny and
submit it is always a pleasure speaking
with you any final words on how to make
a marriage work between an American and
an Indian you need to lose that attitude
a little bit it's really out of
control all right next week on part two
of the tell all Danielle opens up about
catching Johan cheating when I came home
from New York I walked in to a very
unfortunate situation in my
apartment you've been bringing women
there the whole time that was your
horror
[Music]
hotel are you
serious I'm curious about why she still
living in the Dominican Republic and
they aren't together does she plan to
leave that's what I want to know all
right 90day fan spam thanks for hanging
with me make sure you stick with ET
because we are covering it all I will
see you next time
[Music]